and medicine
at stanford and um this is the second
time that that i have had the privilege
of meeting elsie and the first time uh
it was just so interesting and i'm so
glad that you're back um here at dmice
and another super interesting topic to
talk about so thank you again for coming
and for everyone to listen to this and
um take it away please dr ross
thank you so much dr mohamed um that was
a very kind introduction happy to be
here this early afternoon with you
wonderful people um
it's always great to hear your ideas so
half of this time will be used just to
show and discuss what
i think about in my lab but the other
half is just open for discussion so feel
free to ask questions along the way um
i'm not tight on schedule at all for
this hour um so as mentioned i am a
vascular surgeon and a data scientist um
today i'm wearing my data scientist hat
otherwise i'd be wearing these scrubs
which you know are beautiful and all but
sometimes you gotta get out of the or to
try to improve patient care
um so the agenda for today and this is
the first time i'm using this
presentation format so apologies for any
um mishaps but the agenda for today is
really to um
talk about uh precision medicine and
i'll start with the definition of
precision medicine
as well as to talk about some use cases
in cardiovascular disease we use in the
lab
or have experimented with in the lab and
some
conclusions and thoughts about future
directions
although i have an agenda i do not have
a financial one um so i have no
financial disclosures
um so precision medicine again like big
data like machine learning it's a topic
that gets the it's words that get thrown
around a lot um and so in terms of its
definition um i take from it i
define it kind of how the nih
has defined precision medicine for their
main initiative which is an emerging
approach for disease prevention and
treatment that takes into account a
person's individual variation in genes
environment and lifestyle so that we're
not talking about treating people based
on averages but taking into account
multiple factors that can
lead us to
getting the treatment
and prevention of disease better
leading to better long-term outcomes so
although precision medicine is exciting
i think there are a lot of fields that
have not quite got on the bandwagon but
cancer care and
and oncology in general um has really
taken it by the horns and we've seen
some really great um uh work in this
field specifically in cancer so causes
of cancer we all know that cancer is
caused by multiple things like smoking
obesity poor diet sedentary behavior and
genetics um
in the field of cancer oncology or
oncology and precision prior to this
whole precision medicine initiative
you'd have a
diverse group of patients hopefully you
could diagnose the type of cancer they
had and then you'd offer them one of
three treatments whether that be
chemotherapy radiation and or surgery
but with
tons of money invested and time and a
focus on this idea of precision medicine
there are now ways to more precisely
diagnose
a patient's cancer type
and then target therapy specific
for them and although this sounds great
there's actually data that's quite
numerous um
in its um scope about how um precision
medicine can actually affect outcomes
for cancer therapy so in this paper
specifically from a group out at ucsd
looking at um
precision medicine for cancer therapy
they describe
this single institutional
multi-discipline multidisciplinary tumor
board
and the idea of this tumor board was to
enable a comprehensive review of patient
data including molecular profiling and
what's known as n of one treatment plans
that means that they would get um they
would get as much data from the
individual as possible
and then come up with treatment plans
with chemo regimens that or radiation
regimens that match with the patient's
um unique
expression data this included tissue and
blood next generation sequencing mrna
expression analysis and as well as
immunohistochemistry
in the end um in the study as described
they were left with 429 patients um that
were included in their study this
included about 62 percent of people who
could be evaluated and matched to at
least one drug meant um recommended by
this multi-institute multi-um
institutional uh
this
tumor board um as well as 20 of these
patients who are matched to all drugs
that the tumor board um had uh
recommended including combination
therapy and interestingly even though
all of these patients were reviewed by
the tumor board almost 40 percent did
not receive something that the tumor
board had recommended based on the
patient's um specific profile but
instead uh received
chemotherapy regimens based on a
physician's choice when they look back
at the physician choice versus
what the patient's genetics or
biological
markers actually match to they found
that there was a lot of discordance and
that physicians often chose things that
were unmatched or had low match
and the interesting thing is that this
allowed to compare outcomes um for
patients who received um tumor board
recommendations based on their unique
profiles versus those who didn't and
what they found was that in terms of
progression-free survival and um for the
specific tumors people who received the
recommended medications and were well
matched had better um progressions free
survival than those who just received
the physician's choice of regimen which
often was not well matched um similarly
when looking at overall survival um
there is a significant difference for
those who receive therapy that from
where they matched all recommended
recommended therapies versus those with
physician choice or just uh receive part
of their recommended medications and so
you can start to see why precision
medicine can be exciting because at
scale when you're looking at um finding
individuals and matching them well to
treatment um algorithms you can see
potentially how
you can significantly improve survival
overall
so going to cardiology i feel and you
know the precision medicine is just
becoming a thing and becoming more
exciting in cardiology but the research
um in this space has mostly been focused
on
large randomized trials which is great
but it's a different approach so
cardiology and cardiovascular disease in
general very similar that the risk
factors for disease include smoking
obesity so lifestyle things as well as
genetics
and you have this diverse group of
patients but mostly the idea has been
let's get a lot of patients enrolled in
a randomized trial and figure out if
this treatment is effective or not
and the randomization process will make
this a higher fidelity
result and based on this if we find a
treatment to be effective we
you know prescribe it to the right group
of people but what we are missing out on
is that the in a randomized trial you're
really just getting average treatment
effects which means that some people
will do really well um from the
treatment and some people might actually
be quite harmed from the treatment and
so
what as it for precision medicine
applications you can imagine a case in
which we can identify unique
characteristics or unique subgroups of
patients for which they'll do really
well and those who will be really harmed
and so then you can match them
appropriately to treatments to improve
outcomes
what about vascular surgery the field
that i spend most of my time uh dealing
with well it's sort of crickets um
we a lot of our data unfortunately is
anecdotal we have small patient
populations and um in rare circumstances
we do have randomized controlled trials
um and so on one sense you can say all
the vascular or most of vascular surgery
is precision medicine in that we're
really looking at unique patient
characteristics that will drive us to um
offer one surgery or another or not
offer any operation but at the same time
the
data that we're using to make these
decisions aren't that granular and that
we paint broad strokes and so for me
that the interest has been how do we
change this how do we improve our
ability to identify unique subgroups or
identify people for which screening
treatment can be more precisely applied
so in terms of use cases i just want to
describe two
specific use cases of research we've
done in the lab
one that looks at
cardiovascular disease in general and
one that looks specifically at vascular
disease
so for this study
we the idea was
the concept that cardiovascular patients
are diverse there are different subtypes
of disease that we know intuitively and
this may warrant different approaches to
treatment um so the idea for this study
was to evaluate the feasibility of
identifying these unique subgroups using
a lot of different types of data and
using and applying um machine learning
algorithms known as unsupervised
learning algorithms so when i say
heterogeneous data i'm talking about
data from
multiple different factors like clinical
data like blood pressure medication used
to genetic data to lifestyle data and
physical activity
um and unsupervised learning um a lot of
people in this group are probably
familiar but just the thirty thousand
foot few is uh it's there are different
types of algorithms that aim to find
patterns within the data without
pre-specifying
any specific variables or pattern to
which you want the data to be structured
we use a very specific
type of unsupervised learning algorithm
for this study known as generalized low
rank modeling what this allows you to do
is take a feature matrix which includes
patients their demographics clinical
lifestyle and genetic profiles and then
summarize them into two different
matrices which look at their latent
features so changing all of the
heterogeneous disparate data types into
small mathematical um
numbers in a feature space that then
allows you to then look at these latent
features and cluster them so that you
can identify unique clusters of patients
and then to re-identify all the features
that make those clusters unique
and so in this study um we used data
from a clinical trial that included um
about
over a thousand patients who were
presenting for coronary angiograms and
we had
about 160 variables for each of these
patients including clinical
genetic markers environmental exposures
and physical activity
applying our generalized low rank
modeling
algorithm we were able to identify four
different clusters uh when we plotted
them on a feature space
what was fascinating about this is okay
we found four different clusters that's
interesting what we never modeled were
their outcomes and so we took these four
clusters and looked at okay what are are
there any differences in the outcomes of
these clusters and interestingly we
found that um
belonging to this cluster was each
cluster was associated with a different
risk of major adverse cardiovascular
events which in and of itself is quite
fascinating
we didn't pre-specify any variables that
this algorithm needed to use but in its
summary it identified these four unique
groups who had different um
cardiovascular outcomes the other
fascinating thing is that these patients
had different genetic profiles um so red
being hot means that um
uh one cluster like that particular uh
genetic risk factor is uh over
represented in one cluster in blue
meaning that it's underrepresented and
these um risk um snips on the left
represent um risk of cardiovascular
disease and peripheral artery disease
and you can see that it varies across
clusters
and so when we looked this is the idea
of re-identifying what
risk factors or what factors
were in each cluster it was quite
fascinating as well so in cluster one we
had a group of patients who were um
oldest amongst all the clusters they had
more comorbidities than anyone else they
were more likely to have peripheral
artery disease they're more likely to be
smokers and they had a higher risk of
mortality cluster two included these
young multi-ethnic individuals who
almost exclusively all had diabetes also
had a more sedentary lifestyle and um
had lower educational
attainment and socioeconomic status
cluster three and cluster four were
closer to each other but were different
in uh unique ways so for whatever reason
cluster three um involves a a
middle-aged group of individuals who um
often were not taking medications as
prescribed and cluster four looked like
the healthiest in our cohort but
actually had a higher risk of major
adverse cardiovascular events than
cluster three and one thing we found
that was different was that in cluster
four they had a higher um proportion of
patients with higher genetic risk of
cardiovascular disease
um and so as a clinician if you're
if you've ever went to medical school if
you ever taken care of these patients
this is all intuitive and so the
question is like why is this interesting
it's interesting because you can apply a
machine learning algorithm to identify
these clusters at scale so you can
consider if you're looking at population
health and trying to manage a whole
population of individuals if you can
quickly
you know parse them out into different
types of um clusters for which there
might be different approaches to
treatment then you can potentially
improve um outcomes by being more
specific about what treatment you offer
so for instance in cluster two with
young individuals with diabetes and low
socioeconomic attainment maybe your
approach has to do more with
determinants of health whereas in
cluster four these are people with
healthy behaviors which you don't who
you don't expect to have a high
level of cardiovascular risk but they
ultimately do and this might be driven
by genetics and so maybe you institute
genetic screening for this cluster of
individuals so this is just one study of
which um had some fascinating um
outcomes which is um which is submitted
and hopefully will be accepted
sometime soon
um so then the next idea is around
vascular surgery or vascular
disease in general
and peripheral artery disease
specifically so this is the domain and
space i work in a lot which is dealing
with people who have
atherosclerosis that builds up in the
lower extremities leading to poor blood
flow this can lead to limb
loss due to amputation from poor blood
flow or it can um lead to multiple other
things like cardiovascular death stroke
etc because this atherosclerotic buildup
is kind of throughout um the body
um it affects over 200 million uh
individuals worldwide but it's generally
under diagnosed and often providers and
patients don't even know what pad is and
so they don't know to screen for it they
don't know that the symptoms
that a patient's experiencing are due to
this disease process and so it um
leaves a lot to be desired in terms of
how do we best identify and medically
manage these people aggressively so they
don't come to my office to have a
procedure um and it also costs a ton of
money to treat these patients and so
again that idea is are there ways to
identify these patients early on and
improve their medical optimization
so during my postdoc time i was very
interested in how we could leverage
electronic health records because it is
the center of all that we do in the
hospital and as um in taking care of
patients and so it contains a ton of
data and also it contains the
opportunity to um push data insights
onto providers in you know a way that's
useful and not overwhelming hopefully
and so this project uh centered around
using electronic health record data to
automate detection of vascular disease
um and so some of you
if you've ever worked with electronic
health record data if you know of what
common data models are may be familiar
with this schematic but it's the idea
that electronic health records have tons
of data and we want to make that that
data useful and one way to do that is to
standardize um data across different
elements in the electronic health
records system um this is specific
specific to the odyssey work group where
they came up with the common data model
known as omop and so this is the common
data model we use at stanford for our
ehr research
and the idea here was to take this
common data model
and
transform our ahr data into a machine
readable format which is just a bunch of
tables that we can join etc
to then apply machine learning
algorithms or just traditional risk
factor models to then try to detect who
has vascular disease or pid specifically
and who doesn't the idea again being
that because we're pulling data from the
ehr we can automate the running of these
models and then um alert physicians or
even patients that they might be at risk
of this disease and that they should be
screened
to build these models um it we inputted
a lot of ehr data so um to be specific
cases were defined as people who had a
pid diagnosis and controls were people
who had no pid diagnosis for cases we
included
data up until 60 days before their pid
diagnosis to try to model the idea that
we don't know if this patient has pid
but um we want to identify what risk
factors uh are suggestive of pid
and in controls all of their data was
included although we also modeled using
only 60 days of data or using data 60
days prior to their end of follow-up
and in terms of the data we used it was
ehr data including vitals lab
medications diagnoses procedure codes
radiology reports etc and the task here
was to classify does this patient have
pid or not
so um
looking at our model performance we
first started with our traditional risk
factor model this was to say we
predefined
people who had hypertension
hyperlipidemia obesity and we assigned
points and said if you have so many
points as a cut off you have a high risk
of pid and if you fall under that number
your risk is low and the idea here is
that like i'm excited about machine
learning but maybe
you don't need machine learning
necessarily to get the best ball of
performance and so um we use it kind of
as a benchmark for what our
other models will um
have in pro
performance
um so our traditional risk factor models
actually perform quite well when you
look at something as area like area of
the curve
to see how well the model discriminates
between cases and controls we reach aucs
of up to nearly 0.83 and if you look at
calibration curves how good is the model
at modeling
actual risk of disease across the
population of interest the calibration
is decent it's not perfect but it's
decent
so then we're interested in applying
machine learning models specifically
models like random forest which are
great at identifying features
automatically identifying features that
are useful so you can feed um these
machine learning models um a lot of data
that might be sparse and um their bet
and random force we found has been
better at identifying good features and
then coming up with models with good
discrimination and here
here too we found that the models
performed quite well
better than our traditional risk factor
models with similar
results in terms of the calibration
now what we don't model with machine
learning or traditional risk factors is
timing of health care and this is where
um i was interested in applying deep
learning to because a patient comes in
they
have a problem they get a medication
maybe or a certain test they come in
months or days later or years later and
have a different problem and diagnosis
and etc and so care is across time and
not necessarily static for our machine
learning models and our traditional risk
factor models we're feeding just um
the all of the patients data into these
models
whereas what we really want is what
happens to a patient over time and if we
model that will that improve our ability
to detect which patients have pid and
which don't and here we found that our
models performed really well better than
our previous models and of course um for
the data scientists out there when you
see aec starting to approach one you're
like that's definitely overfit um and it
might be
we tried to account for that by breaking
up our data into different folds but
number one we know that this model
performs quite well but number two we
know that we also have to validate this
outside of our stanford data to make
sure that the performance that we're
seeing is also um as good as we think
we also because um the models may be
quite over more over fit than our other
models the calibration curves um vary
quite a bit depending on the different
um populations that are sampled
so while i was working on all this i'm
going to you know build this models i'm
going to implement them in the ehr and
then i'm gonna
see how this does in terms of patient
outcomes
there was this wonderful paper that was
published looking at the genetics of
peripheral artery disease and for those
who don't work in the pid space like
it's very rare for there to be actual
good data about the genetics of vascular
disease because we tend to a lot of the
studies prior tended to have smaller
sample sizes um but this one was based
on a newer data set known as the million
veterans program
which had the goal of enrolling 500 000
or at least 500 000 veterans in the
united states and detailing
a ton of data about them including their
ehr data and also sending out surveys
and supplementing all of that with
genetics which you can imagine is
mind-blowing in terms of the amount of
data that includes and how you can start
linking phenotype data with genetic data
and so um with this publication we
finally had in you know the field of
vascular medicine and vascular disease
results that showed that there were a
panoply of genetic risk factors for
vascular disease and so it was this
light bulb moment where
i thought okay now we can use this
genetic data and improve our ehr models
because
now you can maybe improve the
specificity of the model by identifying
all these unique genetic risk factors
that a patient might have and identify
um these patients more specifically
based on their genetic data
and so
in using gene
in using this type of genetic data and
our electronic health record data i had
this idea that we would build this
precision screening platform stanford
has this precision health bio bank
which has all this rich genetic data or
so i've been told great i have expertise
in using electronic health records to
build models and we're going to combine
that and we're going to be able to
offer this to all patients who come to
stanford this type of precision
screening now for vascular disease but
in the future for any number of diseases
and be able to really make a dent in
patient outcomes
and so when you look at genetic data
there's a lot of different ways to try
to summarize that data or to use that
data you can do things like rare
variants where you're looking at very
specific
and small numbers of
genetic risk or you can look at
something more global like a polygenic
risk score and i chose to use a
polygenic risk or one because it's um
less costly and two because i think it's
easier to translate
across institutions because um you're
looking at a smaller
number of genetic risks so when you
build a polygenic risk or the idea is to
um take either a handful of patients
genetic risk factors and summarize them
and come up with a score or you can look
across the entire genome and summarize
all the little risks that when added
together may be able to um detect risk
of something like vascular disease on a
more um efficiently
and so um the idea was to take
electronic health record data and then
the polygenic risk score and combine
them um again to try to improve our
ability to detect vascular disease and
maybe even detect vascular disease risk
early because we're born with our
genetics and for the most part um
you know depending on our environmental
exposures they um can speak to our
disease risks overall and so maybe you
can identify the 40 year old
before they develop pad
at least that was the thought
um but this is where i ran into a lot of
roadblocks and um maybe now i'm speaking
to people in the audience who are
building labs or um thinking of building
labs so i had expertise in one domain i
found collaborators to try to um
branch out that expertise but there are
a lot of things that i did not consider
so for one despite you know the touting
of our precision health bio bank it only
has very few patients so like the
million veterans program has 500 000
patients
um the um if you look at biobanks like
at vanderbilt or you pen even they have
tens of thousands of patients and then
when i did more digging the stanford
biobank has about four thousand patients
and doing chart review i found about 50
with p80 so i was starting to play with
smaller numbers than i expected
the other issue i ran into was that i
thought the biobank met that all the
genetic all the data had been genotyped
and i just had to pull the data for
analysis it turned out that no um they
had samples that then each individual
lab could pay money
to then have genotyped um and so
i don't pipette um i don't know how to
do any of this analysis and so it took
um a few months to figure out um number
one a collaborating lab that would help
me transfer these samples into wells
that could then be analyzed and number
two to find a cost-effective
way to get these samples genotyped
while stanford has some genotyping
services they're quite expensive and so
we had to look for other partners um
around the bay area to help us with this
um and lastly
once you know we got all the wells set
up um my post doc or the postdoc working
in the lab who um was seminal in this
work had to leave the country do the the
covet 19 pandemic etc and so she wasn't
around to help with
figuring a lot of this out which
included the logistics of getting this
these samples to a lab which
i just threw in the back of my car one
day and drove down to the lab to hand
them the samples to get the genotyping
done so it's all these little nitty
gritty things that
you figure out as you're trying to
branch out of your research expertise
but
after all that all was said and done uh
we actually had some preliminary results
and these are very early like two weeks
ago um we
were able to analyze this um and so we
haven't added the ehr component to it
but we had the genetic component so
again it was a very small sample size
smaller than i expected but it included
52 people with pde and 229 people
without p.d
this was chart review so um
it was manual chart review but i should
have a caveat that says that these 229
controls um because p80 is under
diagnosed it's not 100 guarantee that
these people don't have pd um but to the
best of our ability we look through
their charts to say to try to rule out
um a diagnosis of pd um most of the
people are older pids tends to affect an
older population and most of the or the
majority of these patients were male um
and we know that symptomatic phd at
least um tends to occur in males and so
this you know if you're working in a
tertiary care center um that's more
likely what you're going to see all
right so then we looked at our genetic
data and specifically the area under the
curve so if we just looked if we just
looked at the age race and sex
we achieve at auc
0.709 so 0.71 and then we added this
polygenic risk score you know the blood
sweat and tears that went into trying to
even get the genetic data to do this and
we saw that it added something
but not a lot
so that was kind of depressing
i was expecting like you know we're
gonna add the polygenic risk score and
it was going to tell us so much more
about um our patients but um
you know that's science and that's um
trial and error and at the same time
we're not discouraged by these results
we do see some delta improvement and so
the idea will be to add the electronic
health record data um and to see if um
maybe with less
ehr data the genetic data will have a
higher fidelity and discriminating cases
and controls so more to come on
this horizon
so
so some parting thoughts or some
conclusions i've come to in doing a lot
of this research is that precision
medicine is really exciting and i think
there are a lot of um awesome use cases
that will come up in the future but
currently a lot of genetics genomics or
what we talk when what we talk about
when we think about precision medicine
has more to do with the science of
medicine and less to do with the
practice it's really rare to find use
cases for which clinicians can take that
insights from what a study did and then
use it in their um
daily practice or
tools and things that are actually
implemented um that people can use and
so there's gonna have to be a lot more
focus on how do we move from the science
of precision medicine into the practice
um and then the other idea is that we'll
have to develop more
in developing these tools we'll have to
be very careful about the use cases that
we're considering and
the data that we use so because um of
where i am who my collaborators are the
ehr genetic data seemed like the easy
thing to put together but you can
imagine like using
applying precision medicine using data
from social media or physical activity
data that we're collecting from um
mobile applications um
and so um there's a lot of new research
in these fields and i think that that's
where um a lot more
excitement is going towards
and implementation is difficult i didn't
even really touch on the implementation
piece um and part of this talk but i'm
happy to talk more about that um as part
of the discussion but um at least for
the ehr models what we're doing now is
doing a pre-implementation study where
we're actually going out to primary care
physicians cardiologists and say and um
presenting them with model results or
mock model results and trying to get a
sense of number one how likely are
physicians to believe in our models do
they think that that what our models are
are telling them about a patient's risk
of pid is true um if we use black box
models where we don't really know why
the model says the patient's high risk
are they still likely to trust that um
and what other data do they need to
trust our models
would they act on our model predictions
um and so that's where we're at and
after that um we're still working on
validation studies to make sure that our
models um actually
perform as well as we think they do by
enrolling people
prospectively
and lastly the idea is to
eventually work with epic and other
vendors
to put these models into um into the
clinic and to see whether or not they
have the impact that we expect them to
have
and so with that i say thank you for
your time and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you chelsea for that absolutely
great presentation and so i can actually
start off with a question and i'm really
actually
um curious to know a little bit about
your thoughts of implementing this and
how you how you how how do you think
your research will become actionable um
and if there is actually scope for what
you're doing to translate to other
diseases apart from
um apart from just pid yeah so
the
the implementation process is difficult
because you have to
have money
identify stakeholders who care
and work with teams that can uh make it
happen so in our specific use case um
and talking to so um at stanford we have
this work group that's interested in um
taking the ai models that are coming out
of research labs and implementing them
um but this this work group sits in
stanford healthcare the hospital system
not the university research system and
so what they've found is that they can
get the hospital excited about quality
improvement projects so
not you know about genetics and science
and precision medicine and wow this is
really cool um that we can identify
these patients but
does that do these models improve the
quality improvement initiatives that you
know medicare might um have incentives
for um does this model reduce our costs
improve our profits so very
business-like um metrics that they're
interested in so to to so to work in
working with that work group that ideas
that we
to
finally implement these models we
actually have to come to tailor them to
um align more with hospital financial
and business incentives and so um my
current thoughts and what we're
currently working to do is come up with
um like a broader system of models so
not just for pad but for cardiovascular
disease in general and there are
multiple labs working on different
models and so can we combine efforts to
develop multiple models that can say
show up in one tab in epic that says
your patient has high risk of
pid or your patient has familial
hypercholesterolemia
as one model that's being tested or your
patient's not on a statin and should be
on a statin and sell that as like this
will improve patient outcomes it will
ultimately make stanford more
competitive
it'll improve medication adherence and
so then maybe the hospital will be more
interested and help us implement these
these models and actually get to patient
care
in terms of the broader
scope
while i'm
passionate all day about vascular
disease i really do want to see this
apply to many different things
and especially when you think of
disparities
and outcomes
can you deploy these models in a way
that enables um
identification of people who are at risk
who are not being identified because of
um
lack of access um or
you know racial disparities that might
lead to um poorer health outcomes etc um
and so that applies to multiple
different things it applies to cancer
care applies to cardiovascular disease
um it applies to surgical care and so
um i feel and you know
again this is more like putting my early
faculty hat on just focusing on the
things that i can control and do and the
data that i understand and then
hopefully you know as part of an r grant
and a larger
multi-institutional project is how do we
develop a pipeline that allows for
people to add on their disease use cases
and still come up with a product or tool
that's useful for their
patient population
thank you
hi elsie this is mina i'm a phd student
here can you hear me yep
yeah hi um i was wondering um you should
uh you used your traditional models
machine learning deep learning and you
had a like a 60 day
uh
prior to diagnosis of pid
ehr data uh did you use that for your
deep learning model as well like do you
see any value of increasing the amount
of data that would go into the deep
learning model and also um the second
question is
when you
tested what kind of model did you test
your
final uh
you know with the genetic information
the final slide that you had yeah what
model was that
so that the final slide was just a
logistic regression um like if you plop
in
these small number of variables um what
is the performance of this model um for
the deep learning models um
the
they do tend to need a lot more data
than the other models and to to
have better performance
in terms of the days of
data that we use it was the same 60 days
before diagnosis
that's another
area of research that we hadn't quite
gotten into which was if we um
if we move that to include 10 days
before diagnosis or you know two years
before diagnosis what these how will
these models perform um that variable um
will likely need to be applied to our
general ehr models but i'm more
interested in how that variable performs
if you have the genetic data so if i
have the genetic data i only have 30
days worth of um ehr data on a patient
will that genetic data improve the model
performance versus if i have a whole
year's worth of ehr data the genetic
data might not be that useful
um another question i had was um
did you uh i mean
if the deep learning model can be um
um explained uh we can um there's a way
to get the top 10 or top 20
you know features that were important
in the model
performance so were you able to kind of
see
um
what top features you got in across the
different kind of models that you used
to answer that yeah so there are a few
ways to do that um we haven't done it
yet
we've mostly
focused on the performance of these
models
this pre-implementation study of whether
or not people understand it and then the
the other piece of this research is the
utility um looking at um cost versus how
useful these models will be um i suspect
in going through paper drafts revisions
etc um we'll then finally sit down and
focus on how do we make the deep
learning model more explainable but that
is definitely a planned part of the
research process
thank you
thank you for your questions
healthy is it okay if i ask you a
question
of course
i was actually really curious about um
your discussion
about the
stanford healthcare and its kind of
reaction towards implementing these
prediction models
my question is you know are there
already some clinical prediction models
in place at stanford i would imagine so
and then
you know what are people
you know i know that you're just
starting to look at pre-implementation
acceptability of predictive models but
what have you found so far about
you know what people's kind of reactions
are to these things
yeah so
it's like the emperor's the emperor has
no clothes or the emperor's new clothes
i can't remember what the exact
reference is but it's like there's all
this stuff we talk about precision
medicine stanford yay hoorah but like
there is one model
that is currently implemented and it has
to do with death um and palliative care
and when to offer palliative care to
patients um and that is running off a
server in a in one lab and then it gets
piped into epic um as and then it just
generates a list for the palliative care
team to look at and to start um
uh addressing uh palliative care needs
and that is it even though we have a ton
like there's we've got a ton of labs who
have developed all these great models
but the implementation piece is where
everything comes to a halt unfortunately
um and like i said this work group is
trying to um is trying to um
understand how to decrease that friction
um in terms of the
implementation piece um so i i am not
doing those interviews that's being done
by one of our vascular surgery residents
who's then going to summarize them in a
qualitative format and then um we can
start writing about that those
interviews started last week so we're
very early in the
pre-implementation uh research process
um
but the is so i guess the interesting
thing this year there is like we sent
all these emails out to people like hey
uh we're we want to deploy these models
but we want to get your feedback um on
how we should deploy these models um it
probably went out to like
a thousand people and we probably heard
from like 10 15 people
um so it's really i mean that's just to
say that it's really hard to do these
studies to pin people down um but the
people who replied are really interested
in this and so
it probably will introduce some bias
into
how um these things are assessed but at
least for now it's the best that we can
do um
just to get some feedback because i
think without feedback you're kind of in
this vacuum of believing what you're
doing is um super valuable and so any
feedback at this point would be helpful
from the non-echo chamber of my division
the the various divisions i work in
it sounds like you're going to have some
interesting results to report so we'll
look out for that paper yeah yeah i mean
i'm excited that we got to this point
i'm excited that there are volunteers
any other questions for dr ross
i just went through chat and i don't see
that case
give folks i think 10 minutes of their
time back thank you so much elsie for
taking the time to um to come and chat
with us i think this is really useful
and i think from for me just this idea
of having these trains of
you know models just not just for one
disease but you know the smoker who has
hypertension with peripheral vascular
disease who has copd all of it kind of
bundled together in a way that's
meaningful that's just you know that's
super exciting yeah thank you guys so
much for your time and look forward to
future conversations and
continuing to learn from your group and
others
all right bye guys
bye thank you
i'll go ahead and in the meeting
thank you for
joining our conference today
thank you no problem